I'm not sure if this relates to contrast
but to say that the audience loves
contrast I think you talked about in one
of your videos if a character comes in
angry then they need to leave with some
resolve or or happy something but if
they come in happy then they need to
leave the scene angry there needs to be
some kind of a contrast yeah that's
that's a principle I learned from you
know just reading Robert McKee basically
that the idea is that a scene turns on
the emotional state of of the character
or characters and basically the idea is
that by contrast the whole point of
story is to get us to engage emotionally
so what when we're tracking something
you know the the logic should be as it
should be as logical as it needs to be
so that we can emotionally invest in
something so something needs to be
logical if it within the confines of the
world just enough so that we can care
about what they care because what we
really are interested in is what is the
emotional state of these characters so
and the best way to know if a scene is
turned is if the character comes in with
this you know positive emotion they
experience some conflict and the results
causes a shift if they come in
happy and they leave happy
generally speaking nothing significant
has happened and so what we're what
we're looking for when we're structuring
our scenes or what I'm looking for when
I'm structuring my scenes is some sort
of emotionally significant experience
that changes the way they're seeing
their situation and then from there
using their strategy they adapt to to
new conflicts is that the one where you
used Glengarry Glen Ross yeah I think
you use some of that maybe it wasn't
that one you know mammoths Creed is what
does the character want why now and what
happens if they don't get it you know so
it's asking those three questions which
form a kind of litmus test to whether
the scene is worth it and then from
there you know a taking Maki's principle
of
of turning the scene from a positive to
a negative or negative to a positive and
the idea of contrast is basically what
what I was trying to say is that we want
to pace out of film and it shouldn't be
just ridiculous jumps in contrast if she
comes in like if a main character comes
in and she's just exploding with joy and
then hits the depths of sorrow
that's melodrama and we begin to
disengage or just you know I mean
there's plenty of exceptions to this but
but ultimately what we're looking for is
a kind of journey which means we're
we're we're following the emotional
journey that they're going through with
ups and downs and usually some shifts
and then sometimes it drops out from
under you
so a lot of that is about understanding
the way you can pace out and establish a
rhythm of different scenes and you start
to develop certain stakes and then you
drop it and raise the stakes and things
like that so it's all about playing with
the expectations and getting the
audience to guess what's gonna happen
next so are those the three questions
sometimes you'll ask with your care avy
even supporting characters not just the
protagonist or the antagonist but just
some of the supporting ones yeah so a
lot of thing about about structure
especially is largely to do with
rewriting although that does inform
outlining as well that's all the
principles inform each other a lot of
the story structure theory like for
example especially like scene dynamics
that that video was largely due to kind
of like almost like checklist of once
you've already written a scene these are
some ways to know if it's working or not
so I took Mamet's Mamet's Creed and I
took Robert maki's principle of like
turning from the emotions up to positive
negative and vice versa and then I came
up with a list of like essential scene
dynamics and a lot of that just it's
kind of like a checklist of something
that I'll be reading something I'll I'll
make sure that each scene that I write
has these elements and if they don't
have the elements then it's then usually
I can diagnose exactly what's what's
wrong with it what's not working with it
you